in half an hour tower bridge is going to
open its bascules
the bascules of the bit that the road
sits on down below a sailing barge
called
will wants to pass through the bridge
and so the bridge must
lift that's going to delight the
tourists but it's going to delay
thousands of drivers cyclists and
pedestrians and cause tailbacks for
miles and the team here are going to let
me push the button to do it
but before we get to that point there's
a lot of work to be done by a lot of
different people
salem badge will tower bridge radio sale
bridge radio
station will good morning good morning
to you just to let you know that we are
standing by for your 10 30 bridge lift
we work really closely with a number of
agencies with the port of london
authority responsible for the river
with transport for london with the
police as well and also the local
boroughs the bridge is sat
between two boroughs of london half of
it's in tower hamlets
and half of it in southwark so in terms
of transport network we need
really close uh working relationships if
we know that for example there's an
ambulance on the way
we'll hold off from starting the process
tower bridge is a tourist attraction
these days that's why we've got the
behind the scenes tours and the glass
floors up on the walkways but
it's still a working bridge and it can
be opened must
legally be opened to let river traffic
through any hour of any day
there was this one time back when
clinton and blair
were in power and i think their timings
ran over slightly and the motorcade
started to come back
across the bridge from the south side to
the north and got cut off
by a bridge lift that was due to take
place now at that point the bridge
driver on duty received a call
there's a very important person in the
car that's stuck on the south side of
the bridge
bill clinton at the time the person in
charge said very bravely
no we can't do that i'm afraid the river
traffic has rights over road traffic
but also physics there's a boat bearing
down on us
if we don't raise the bridge it'll
strike the bridge so
they raised the bridge it came through
and they received a lovely letter from
the white house a couple of weeks later
saying
thank you for arranging this brilliant
spectacle for us of tower bridge racing
when tower bridge was built cargo was
unloaded all around here straight into
warehouses
on the riverbank so it was important
that ships could get through the new
bridge here river traffic comes first
trade must not be interrupted that was
laid down in law in 1885 when the bridge
was commissioned
and even though there's no cargo being
unloaded around here these days
that law hasn't changed boats have a
right to pass through here
and removing a legal right of way is
very difficult there have been a couple
of grumbles about it in parliament over
the years but as far as i can tell
no one's ever seriously thought about
changing it so
with 15 minutes to go the engineers are
getting ready for the lift
we do have uh pre-checklists make sure
that
there's no obstructions in the bicycles
we check the oil levels we check
the electrics because we've got high
voltage electricity coming in here so
when the bridge actually
moves it's the initial torque that
you've got to get once it actually
starts moving it's quite
straightforward and nice and easy we've
got four packs on each corner of the
bridge and one hydraulic pack has
two hydraulic motors with two hydraulic
pumps
back in the day up until the early 70s
it was
steam operated what we actually use
today
is very similar to what the victorians
actually put in and these days
is just the electric hydraulics if
you've got a tall enough boat then you
can call tower bridge
24 hours ahead ask for a bridge lift and
they will fit you in
even though you can't really get very
far the next bridge is only about 900
meters down the river and it doesn't
move
and never mind the lifting tower bridge
causes tailbacks and massively
inconveniences
a lot of people if your boat's tall
enough then you've got a right
to get the bridge lifted and about five
minutes time
someone's gonna use that right official
numbers are
six bridge drivers um so there's only
six of us in the world that can actually
do it
takes on average about two years to
train up to be a bridge driver the main
part of being a bridge driver is not
actually raising and lowering the bridge
is known what to do if it goes wrong
if you've got the bridge up in the air
and it breaks down it's a matter of
you've got to be able to fix it as quick
as possible so that you're not
blocking up half of london free driving
control systems have occurred some
standpoint removing structure machinery
and contrast
all right hi tom hello come on in
thank you welcome to the north east
control cabin
thank you very much as you know we're
about to do a bridge lift yeah
it's going to be for the sail and badge
will which is just down the river
just down there all right time is now
10 26 yeah four minutes
so we're gonna go straight into this
let's do it no time to waste
i'm actually nervous so the first thing
i want you to do is start up our
hydraulic pumps okay
so press that button
that will now start the pumps this is a
public announcement
ridge lifting operations are about to
commence standby bridge staff
stopping road traffic if you could just
press the
red traffic light traffic lights
changing to red that's it let go
so now we can press them together at
this puncture done
now we'll press for the pedestrian gates
all right close
yeah just got to wait for for two
casually sauntering tourists going
across the right
this is why we start a little bit early
you have attempts to just start it
raising at this point
press that now all right that's
disengaging yeah so the indication will
show that light's gone off
i'm terrified i've pushed the wrong
button already no
you've done nothing wrong next one is
the nose walls retract the nose bolts
yeah press that button
i feel like you should hold it down for
longer but it's just a quick it's just a
quick tap
reach ready move yep grab hold of the
joystick pull it back slightly
a little bit more all the way
all the way i'll take it all the way
all right in the bridge yeah tell me
when to slow it down
it's going to be a matter of once we get
to the angle you just let go of the
joysticks
now to me from here that looks like 45
already but we're only at 26.
that's right it's uh it's deceiving the
way to see
at the corner of the bridge there you
see that bit of uh iron
with the riveting yeah when that gets
horizontal
that's actually 45 degrees and here
comes the barge that is
much taller than it looks from a
distance 39 degrees
and 41. right so if you
let go of it now and press the green
river light
that's it and sailing barge will is good
to go yep
it's a shame i'm wearing the mask
because you can't see the grin on my
face right now
it's a great feeling when you do it for
the first time yeah
thank you so much you have completed
a bridge that was much more
nerve-wracking
than just pushing some buttons should
have been there there's so much riding
on that
i know it's all automated i know that at
any point you could have pushed me out
the way and stepped in and that's that's
fine but
it's still nerve-wracking when there are
so many people waiting
and so much riding on that for you know
london working
but even now i've done hundreds
of lifts and i still get a buzz out of
it
yeah right how do we get this back down
you